[Applause]
a day of high drama in Peru with vice
president Dina bonuarte being sworn in
as the country's new leader
Pedro Castillo dissolved Congress by
Presidential decree I moved the
country's constitutional Court said was
a coup d'etat
as a result he quickly lost the backing
of his political allies
a coup attempt has been made and
initiatively by Mr Pedro Costello it was
not echoed by any Democratic
institutions or the people following on
from the Constitutional order this
Congress has made a decision and it's my
duty to act accordingly
it was congress's third impeachment
attempt to oust Castillo he tried to
save himself with a bold move
will temporarily dissolve Congress and
establish an exceptional emergency
government while calling for elections
for a new Congress and drafting a new
constitution
[Applause]
curfew but as lawmakers began voting for
the impeachment Castillo left the
presidential palace with his family
police say he was going to request
political asylum in Mexico but instead
he was arrested his supporters clashed
with police outside the station where he
was held throughout his presidency
Castillo had constant confrontations
with the political opposition he was
even expelled from his own party now
lawmakers say they want to work with a
new president
she should come with a cabinet that
helps to deal with problems not
ministers who will only praise her
is the first female president of Peru
she has asked peruvians for Unity and
lawmakers for a truce Sanchez